[Music]
okay let me ask you about karl
Pilkington he is this great discovery
that you made there he is he has a
monkey on his back you found this guy
and basically all you've done is ask him
to be himself he's a fascinating
character honestly I feel like I'm
Antony Hopkins in the Elephant Man yeah
I've got this I found this out of it I'm
taking him around the world where did
you find other ways that this is true
that that's Kip Carl's favorite film the
Elephant Man you know loved cities it
showed it's it's weird I wish I could
have met him but he's dead alright um
and uh there's a bit in it where Antony
Hopkins and shows off John Merrick
and to a group of surgeons and is naked
and Annie hops going you see the
defamation of the spine the limbs are
the only things that are totally normal
and untouched are the genitals and Carl
went think of that the one thing you
would want like an elephant and he gets
the head butts funny is Carl's never
trying to be funny
no joke it's just everything he says
just honestly these talks in one-liners
that comedians would die for well he
doesn't mean them he just he just cuz I
his child like there's never any malice
he's got no filter it's no pretensions
um I sent him around the world because I
knew it'd be have his comfort zone and
it's a show karl Pilkington around the
world you're doing it again
yeah it's called Idiot Abroad he didn't
come up with a tie or we didn't even
know it with the title you saw the
billboards yeah it's great it's like one
big experiment like you know like you
muck around and annoy mates yes I do
that on a global scale yes
we're back backed by millions and I just
I'm just sitting around again idiot of
all three it's coming to Science Channel
next year and you've seemed him up with
someone this time sit right Warwick
Davis who's the the dwarf actor he's an
actor he's a dwarf yeah and you've
titled war factories and actor and he
happens to be a dwarf I don't know why
sound that busy does he doesn't put that
on this um so well yeah because I told
car once that um when I'm at Dick
Whittington he apparently walked to
London and became mayor and he took his
cap and car went why was take a cap he
said he must have walked twice as far
because cats wander and he said also why
didn't he take a little mate so I've
given him a bit we'll make shirts
and you see he gets along with what work
no it does get a little I know they're
arguing all the time it's honestly it's
the best series so far because they just
bicker
and Warwick so gregarious Norman and I
stitched it up so I always gave Warwick
a better room and made sure Carl saw
that and Carl's like in next to a toilet
with like well it's just it's just so
funny and I was I was editing them at
the the final episode and Carl asked
Warwick the funniest question I've ever
had anyone asks and he's totally serious
he said to Warwick he went have you got
knees
[Applause]
it just ah yes yes I have I have guests